Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David, Pee
Wee. This is kind of a funny voicemail
I got my radical Trumpists confused on,
I guess yesterday we were talking about people
associated with Trumpism who are running in 2022,
and I got my Trumpists confused. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, David. Just watching your show. And
I wanted to make a small correction. A German
Jew ski isn't from Michigan. He's from Ohio's
ninth Congressional District. And the other guy
that you interviewed from Michigan was John Gibbs.
I'm sure they all just kind of
run together after a while. Yeah.
Just want to let you know. Thank you. Bye.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's actually exactly what
happened. I was kind of just going from memory
about various Trumpists we've interviewed and
spoken to and whatever. I got the states wrong.
So I apologize. They're they're all still radical
nuts. But I did get the States wrong. And for
that, I apologize because we want accuracy
and precision both on this program. We
have a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about what's happening
in the elections in the Philippines. It is
absolutely fascinating and I think it will be of
interest to many in our audience. We are going to
talk about the new Biden administration proposal
to cap the cost of the Internet for low income
Americans of Internet service. To be clear, and it
seems natural that we would do this, and yet there
are many people that are completely furious
about it. So we're going to talk about that.
And we are also going to talk more about abortion
rights activists demonstrating outside the homes
of Supreme Court justices. We have some opinions
about whether that's okay to do or not. We are
going to get more opinions about that. Producer
Pat will join me. We're going to talk about
ambush journalism, protesting at people's houses,
all these types of things. And there really are
very different views about if and when, if ever,
and when these tactics are okay to use. All of
those stories and more are on today's bonus show.
We do a bonus show every day for our members. You
can sign up and become a member at join Packman
dot com and you can use the coupon code Obama
to become a member. That's Obama anyway. And
just remember Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money. Everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: So just as long as you're comfortable
supporting something Alex Jones hates, sign up.
It's going Pacman. Scott and I will see you.